my favorite disease is arthritis I love
arthritis the reason why I love
arthritis is it's easy to fix and when
you can fix something is horrible and is
debilitating as painful as expensive and
as miserable as arthritis you get kind
of excited about this concept of
preventing and curing diseases with
nutrition and so I tell people about
this arthritis thing all the time so
let's have a quick look at arthritis uh
number one 75 to 80% of all Americans
over the age of 50 get arthritis to one
degree or of one type or another and
according to the CDC the Center for
Disease Control
35 to 50 million baby boomers are going
to get arthritis in the next 7 to 10
years and there's not a single medical
treatment designed to prevent or fix it
aspirin certainly doesn't fix arthritis
cause gastric bleeding and death tanol
doesn't fix arthritis causes 50,000
cases of kidney failure each year 5,000
which are so severe you need a kidney
transplant then there's ibuprofen ad
vill and a leave these things don't fix
arthritis and they cause liver disease
in 2 to 5% of the users including liver
ceros even if you don't drink and then
there's methre and gold shots these
things don't fix arthritis they subdue
your bone marrow so you can't make
normal platelets and white blood cells
and then you have the granddaddies of
all the medical treatments for arthritis
prazone and cortisone they don't fix
arthritis they subdue your immune system
which leaves you open to diseases far
far more horrible than arthritis and
prazone and cortisone accelerate the
loss of minerals from your bone
something you don't want when you have
osteoporosis and arthritis now when
these prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and I I never
like to send my patients in for the
joint replacement surgery because they
never work out well in fact many times
you're worse off after the surgery than
you were before the surgery the
advantage my patients have always had is
that I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and so I always used to tell
my patients look we have all these
nutritional formulas designed to prevent
and cure diseases in animals including
arthritis and so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formulas designed
to prevent and cure arthritis in pigeons
and turkeys dogs cats sheep pigs horses
cows lions tigers and bears to human use
it was no surprise to me it works just
as well in humans as a does in animals
because it was designed to prevent and
cure arthritis and pigs and I've
literally seen tens of thousands of
people who've had a regrowth of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone Foundation bone matrix
doesn't matter if they're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 I've seen people 97 years old
regrow caragen bone even if they had
bone to bone arthritis if there's blood
supply to that joint in that bone they
will regrow bone and carage well of
course Harvard Medical School goes
berserk when you say stuff like that W
like you can't say those things the only
thing left for people when they get bone
to bone arthritis is joint replacement
surgery and I I'd agree with him if the
only raw materials you're using is
Tylenol and aspirin and prazone and
cortisone we've learned over 50 years
that you can't regrow Caren bone using
those things one of the basic things of
course the Harvard Medical School jumped
on to and they said this is so
ridiculous that this couldn't work and
so they took 29 patients arthritis
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis over over 15 to 20 years they
took them off all their medication
wasn't working for them anyway lined
them up for joint replacement surgery
and they said look for 90 days before we
do the surgery they gave him a heaping
tablespoonful of ground up chicken
carage in their orange juice every
morning for 90 days they were sort of
chuckling in their beer saying nothing's
going to happen well here's what
happened in 10 days these people these
29 people had complete relief of pain
inflammation something they hadn't had
in 15 to 20 years in 30 days they can
now open up a new pickle jar that never
been opened without pain to the fingers
wrist elbows and shoulders in 90 days 28
of the 29 were clinically cured now this
is from Harvard Medical School in the
Boston VA that meant that they had
complete return to the range of ocean
all the pain inflammation was gone in
their fingers and toes and hips and
knees and their neck and certainly many
of them still had knots on their fingers
because it was only 90 days and You'
think they'd call me up these professors
you know of medicine from Harvard
Medical School and from the Boston VA
and say look wall we have to apologize
to you we've been bad mouthing you for
20 years and why don't you come up to
Boston let's talk about the whole thing
here's what they said quote after 3
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote chicken cartilage had
become a drug in 90
days now why would that happen well
because you can't patent chicken carage
and uh they convinced at the US patent
office that they were using a drug to do
this study and they actually got a use
patent on chicken carage and you two for
3500 bucks a month can get Harvard
Medical school's chicken carage in a
capsule for arthritis of course
cartilage has Condren sulfate in it
glucosamine sulfate collagen these are
all the basic raw materials to rebuild
carage and Bone